this morning on a special edition of the
dish food with ancient origins helping
women lead modern lives and for that we
go to the Middle East to the nation of
Jordan that's where a cooking school
owner Maria Haddad hanana is keeping her
grandmother's favorite recipes alive by
teaching eager guests how to prepare
them all while helping local women join
the workforce and become more
independent every one of you is making
their own pots I want you to add just
enough to cover that whole I want it to
be like a nice creamy texture this is
actually my grandmother's house and in
Arabic grandmother's house means Beit
City did you all taste the tahini and
when she passed away we decided we
wanted to do exactly what she used to do
and teach guests the dishes that she
used to teach us so what we're gonna do
here is the recipe for Hamas this is my
favorite recipe and it's here that Maria
Haddad Ananya teaches people from around
the world how to cook a traditional
four-course jordanian meal who wants to
make dessert let's go through the
recipes here your grandmother's recipe
yes
what are some of her favorites there
might a little bit and a little bit
literally translated means flipped
upside down it's actually a part that
you make with rice and meat sometimes
chicken sometimes fish it's a pot that
was prepared by farmers a long time ago
using leftover ingredients today we're
making it with excess cauliflowers
because they are in season these recipes
are some of the Dada Ananya's earliest
food memories learned right here in her
grandmother's kitchen my mom didn't know
what to do with that
so she would bring us here and my
grandmother would put us to work to
prepare lunch you know a lot of women
used to think that it was shameful to
work when your mother weren't exactly
what my grandmother you always used to
say was there is no such thing it's
actually shameful if you're not working
but jourdan's a country where women are
not always welcome in the workforce the
World Bank estimates just 22% of women
participate in the labor force compared
with 87 percent of men I'm very happy to
say that we are all a woman's and all
the women's team it's a living that's
transform the lives of a marina mall and
majeeda Muhammad so you feel empowered
no no yes but to me it gives me freedom
Muhammad says to build my own home and
to be more financially independent and
also help other people in my situation
polymerase weed has taught at beit city
for three years I love cooking she says
I love teaching people how to cook and I
love cooking something that is from my
own culture
Taurasi me Surya marah's weed is Syrian
one of the many displaced during the
Civil War what happens when you engage
with people I mean who are not from here
but I learned from them she says I take
a lot of good beautiful things from them
and we learn from each other that's true
for Australian tourists Leeanne Tully
and Cynthia Robinson this is a first
time we've seen women at work then all
the hotels we've been to it's mean men
men men which is good for the economy
but we're wondering where all the women
were now let's talk about how we boiled
chicken bit 60 is great because it
breaks the barrier so it opens up this
platform of communication with the cooks
where they ask them if they're about the
job and about their religion nobody
really is able to answer these questions
unless you talk to a local among Haddad
Hernandez guests the country's most
famous supporter of gender equality
Queen Rania of Jordan on her birthday
back in 2015 the Queen treated a group
of 40 orphans to a cooking class first
of all Queen Rania the way she portrays
Arab women is very impressive because a
lot of people in the West they don't
know what you're the Indian women are
you know they think that because they're
wearing veils they're you know stepped
on by the
husbands they they get told what to do
but this is not actually what the real
deal is still some women who have worked
here have faced struggles at home one
woman was abused by her husband and when
she came here her self-esteem was shot
you know like it was very hard to bring
her back up and the second she starts
giving glasses to these men who are very
interested in hearing what she has to
say she automatically her self-esteem is
boosted and you really see a different
woman and that kind of cultural exchange
can make all the difference I'm so
passionate about what I do I don't feel
like it's work it's so pleasant sitting
with the guests when they come at the
end of the meal because at first it's
always awkward when you meet people mmm
you know it's hard to break this barrier
and the second you start cooking with
them automatically you become friends
you have a shared interest no matter
what's all right back to work now you
work on your salad henna and they're
always in a good mood right because
they're traveling and they're eating
they're never hangry is that the word
okay so here's to Bates City cheers
everybody I know we have to hangry anger
preventing anger may be the key to life
Jordan's interesting story it is she
really exposes the intricacies and
certainly the range of woman in in
Jordan because it is all over the map
and it really is a place where there's a
lot of cultural exchange but oftentimes
women don't get to participate in much
of it amazing to what giving someone the
confidence with that by cooking the
woman that came in there without some of
it good stuff